you know when I bought the Mavs we had
no season ticket-holder base and so
literally it was a matter of just
putting a list of former season ticket
holders and a white pages back ban you
know on my desk next to my phone and
making phone calls you yeah me yeah
because if I'm not gonna do it I'll find
someone else to do it right so just get
on the phone hey this mark you know I'm
the new owner of the Dallas Mavericks
we've you know I'd like to invite you
back were again it's not though this is
my business you can't get regular sales
gets or something make those calls wants
to get to a corner you're a guy that's a
billion you're making them but that's
all you know and that's fine and good
right because everybody's got their own
goals right and but still I don't want
anybody at the Mavs to be able to say
well he's not willing to do the work
right there's you know if I walk around
I'm picking up all the papers I'm not
saying go get that picked up my money
okay that's trash I'm picking it up so
but in terms of speed of growth it's
really you got to get that first
customer first and then when you get
that first what did you learn reiterate
get that next customer